and another guy with getting minutes
here in these these the past few games
has played well
and long range portland answers back
with the three now mccollum lets it go
that's no good
trying to knife in for the rebound was
morris instead collins has it
collins only played six games as lillard
fires up a three now jeremy grant around
collins tries to
finger roll and nurkits the rebound
[Applause]
wow lillard way out and he hits four
from beyond the arc doesn't matter how
far
he had a career high seven threes he's
got six games of 20 or more
he's a very good shooter now lillard
again and the nuggets got to do
something
[Music]
a quiet start now mccollum good defense
by morris
that's as good as you can do lillard
cass off and i think tori craig got to
stay close
[Applause]
dive to shoot really going up splits
through got a good look for three and
hit as the nuggets cut the portland lead
to nine
[Applause]
leveler tough shot i i won't tell you
what go sit out there and try and help
katie try that
finds the open person continues on his
path
it's only right he gets it back in new
york to where he's at now
and like he said he doesn't mind being
the role he is and
they've got two wins as torrey gets
called for the foul the m1
she's just feels you just
not a whole lot that's embarrassed about
that that's my opinion
long range lillard again you have the
roll going you get two really tough
calls against the three for little 775
since then they're on a 23-10 run
all batted away by bull
[Applause]
mccollum or make that and that
is damian lillard can't come off those
screens
let a defender just push you flat
lillard backs up got it again
mustang